uh focusing just in austin because
there's so much going on here and
this is the first time i do a podcast
and i just kind of wanted to
get some feedback or some some kind of
tips on on getting it going or growing
it i mean
right um okay so podcasting's gotten
very popular
and there's a reason podcasting has
gotten popular
it's because the press is so bad today
and i don't mean to say like fake news
in the trump way
i think a lot of press try very hard but
they're under resourced and the subjects
especially the important ones um are not
participating in the way they once did
because they don't feel they're getting
treated properly by the press they feel
like they're getting misquoted
they feel like they're not getting their
story out
but then you look at podcasting you have
20 minutes 30 minutes 40 minutes to get
your story out as a subject as a guest
what's happening is all the great guests
are saying i should
uh not only stop talking to the press or
stop doing
short quick hits on network tv i should
start doing long-form podcasts so we got
an
influx over the last five years of
people saying hey i want to tell my
story on this week in startups
because you're going to take the time to
tell her properly and
then we started to see the next level
which is the people who are great guests
are starting their own podcast so i saw
cyan banister the angel investor who's
been on this podcast a whole bunch
has started her own podcast and so
you'll keep seeing that trend where the
subjects say
enough i'm going to start my own podcast
in fact chamoth paulie hoppitya who's
been on our podcast a lot who does a lot
of hits on cnbc
he's going to we're starting a podcast
together so we're going to do like a
season
of the all in podcast now for you how to
do a great podcast
number one you need great microphones i
cannot stress this enough
you need to have perfect audio this
means you have to be an adult
and have a quiet room you need to have
proper microphones
the shure microphone is the one most
people use but there's plenty of
different microphones out there
use a great microphone have a great
audio engineer
or uh bring the file after you record it
to a great audio engineer
it has to be perfect audio when you turn
on a podcast
in today's day and age if it is staticky
or clicking or low and the levels are
not right people are
they have other choices so they're going
to leave so great microphones number one
number two great guests you want to have
great guests if
you you can find a great guest and you
got to travel to them and do it in their
conference room or you got to
fly to their city it's worth it get the
great guest
guests equal uh ratings and they're
going to share it and
you know the the our show that's being
started has been defined by
some outlier guests who really got us a
lot of attention
um and then consistency if you think you
can do it weekly do it weekly if you
think you do it twice a week do it twice
a week you think you do it every other
week
do it 26 times a year it get you'll get
good at it somewhere between episode 100
and 200.
and your interview skills are important
and the ability to cut somebody off if
they're boring but in an elegant fashion
um and asking short questions
you got to ask short tight questions if
somebody says something on the podcast
as well that
you don't think the audience understands
like they drop a buzzword and you're
ahead of the curve
so somebody here will say you know the
roi on that and say i'll just say very
briefly
the return on investment and they'll say
yeah return on investment
and then well they'll say you know your
ltv and i say you know what would you
explain ltv for somebody in the audience
who has never heard that before
and then sometimes a magical moment will
happen when they'll give a great example
and they'll they'll dig a little deeper
finally
my secret to interviewing people is i
don't have a giant list of questions
that i'm trying to get through
i might have three or four topics i want
to hit but i listen to people's answers
so intently
and i write down keywords so if somebody
was talking and they said you know and
that was you know it was like the time i
met steve jobs and uh
of course then i went to work for amazon
and then i just write down steve jobs
and i say you know you mentioned that
last answer
uh you met steve jobs when did you meet
steve
again short answer but you got to be
present because what you don't realize
is the audience is listening to the
answer
and they're forming their own follow-up
questions if you
can then channel a listener while you're
in an interview which is a difficult
task to do to be that present
but if you can actually channel the
listener
and when you hear them mention something
whether it's an acronym
or an anecdote or just a a side note
they drop like when they say that's
another story
whereby that's a story for another day
you want to write that down and follow
up on that
not necessarily the third or fourth
question you've got written down on your
piece of paper don't be a slave to your
list of questions
be prepared for the interview but don't
be a slave to that list of questions
does that make sense
it does thank you so much any follow-ups
joey
yeah so i mean do you think it i guess
would it become easier once you have
several guests and people kind of start
following you is it i mean
right now it's just been cold calling
people cold emails and i've had some
success but
you know going forward i'm hoping to get
more people on yeah i mean listen you're
starting from zero
i assume you're not like a known
quantity you don't have a hundred
thousand followers on twitter right
right um so but you have a niche austin
startups
i'm not going to austin and interviewing
the 50 startups there
i might have the tops two startups on
the podcast
in the next year or two those other 48
startups are not getting on this week in
startups we're too busy we have
too many people trying to get on the
show but you've got them in your
backyard so you can beat me
this week in startups you can beat me to
those startups and get them when they're
five-person companies which by the way
is what i did to get where i am
a thousand episodes in with six
full-time people working on the podcast
the reason i'm here is because we never
stopped and because in the early days we
had
this kid's kevin from his company
bourbon was failing and he pivoted to
this instagram thing and we had him on
the pod when he had five people we had
this kid travis on
who was in two cities with his you know
uber app
you'll hit one of those just like a
venture capitalist or an angel investor
hits an interesting
investment every 25 to 50 you're gonna
hit some interesting guests every 25 to
50.
so you have to ask yourself well why am
i doing this if you're doing it because
you're passionate about entrepreneurship
and talking to entrepreneurs and telling
their stories
the reward is in the interview it's in
the discussion
so if you love the discussion with
founders that's your reward
and then anything that happens after you
publish for that founder for you
uh for the audience is icing on the cake
i just love having the great
conversation i would do these
conversations anyway i used to do them
over lunch 10 years ago
i would just have lunch with one or two
interesting people a week i was always
trying to book an interesting lunch
or an interesting dinner or an
interesting breakfast that was like my
sport back in the day i'd say hey can i
have lunch with you i want to have
dinner at some point i'd love to share a
meal
and uh people are busy and the podcast
is a much better venue than just doing
lunch or dinner because
they get something out of it it promotes
their business they get to tell their
story
et cetera so and and just try to be a
better interviewer every time
and don't worry about being small don't
worry about getting like
mason companies that's actually your
strength worry about consistency and
quality
are you consistently publishing this
every week
week in and week out a hundred percent
of podcasting is showing up
that's job one you have to show up and
do a hundred episodes
when you hit 100 episodes now you've d
you've actually
become part of the top five percent most
people in podcasting never get to
episode 100.
so your job is to have great audio the
best guess you can
the best conversation you can and get to
a hundred and when you get to 100 you
call back into sj's and i'll tell you
the next secrets awesome sounds great to
me
all right joey get back to work thanks
so much do the work
all right take care all right be good